but not as ridiculous as msnbc's joy
reid because you're not gonna believe
this guys for her this is about
racism
now what we're seeing in ukraine is
absolutely the worst humanitarian crisis
that europe has seen in decades
but we haven't witnessed the same type
of solidarity for the yemenis
as we do for the ukrainians
we don't see historic sanctions or
global campaigns corporations like
airbnb and netflix taking a stand and
this is not to say that we shouldn't
care this much for ukraine far from it
the point is we should also care this
much for refugees and those facing
occupation and war in the middle east
and asia and africa too
the coverage of ukraine has revealed a
pretty radical disparity in how human
ukrainians look and feel to western
media compared to their browner and
blacker counterparts
i just don't even know what to do with
these people anymore like it is so sad
and depressing if at the end of the day
every which way you can see the world is
through the the very very narrow prism
of racism if that's really all you can
do then then your world is small and
myopic and sad and leads you to becoming
sort of bananas as joy reid actually is
i would love i said to my guys as we
were playing the clip just now i would
love to know how many times joy reid has
covered what's going on in yemen on her
show has she been leading has she once
led her show with what's going on in
yemen no of course i'm going to go out
on a limb and assume that no she hasn't
but please prove me wrong i'll gladly
correct myself tomorrow
it is what it is these people are nuts